alors nos camus vous avez commencé à
publier en 1975 et depuis votre oeuvre
surabondante mail roman entretien
ouvrages sur l'art et votre fameux
journal dont vous avez commencé la
publication en 1987 avec journal romain
c'est l'époque vous étiez pensionnaire à
la villa médicis à rome
est ce que vous croyez vraiment que tout
ce qui vous arrive est suffisamment
intéressante pour être noté et pour être
publié et vendu dans les librairies
c'est le fait que d'aller en effet
jusqu'au bout de la vérité ne
considérait la vérité comme à la fois
comme un habile mais comme but ultime
peut présenter un intérêt et oui moi je
crois que n'importe quelle vie si on va
jusqu'aux extrêmes de la réalité enfin
évidemment autant témoigner un peu de
curiosité pour les êtres pour les lieux
un connard pour les choses comme ça mais
oui je crois qu aller jusqu'au bout de
la vérité peut être intéressant est
compris dans ce cas là dès que ça voire
désagréable en particulier pour soi oui
ça peut être facile tous les jours et
neuro en effet les moments où c'est une
sorte d'ascèse peu ça peut être
désagréable au dessus alors aujourd'hui
vous publiez le 14e journal celui de
l'année 1999 et ça s'appelle retour à
canossa
m
vous racontez renaud camus dans ce
journal vos amours homosexuelles
notamment avec un certain farid ali
marocain de 21 ans avec qui vous avez
publié incomparable ans en 1999
vous racontez pas mal d'histoires de
bèze homos dans les hammams
en effet ça vous intéresse
oui je m'intéresse beaucoup à la vapeur
ça vous fait j'aime bien aux bus c'est
l'été une grande partie de ma vie en
effet il ya tout un tas de descriptions
de relation physique assez crus parfois
des digressions historiques et
littéraires vous êtes très cultivé ça
c'est clair
1 vous montrer en plus j'espère je peux
pas trop gamin mille bosco l'occasion
son poison
j'ai la chance d'être curieux oui
beaucoup de choses vous êtes des
problèmes de macintosh vous racontez vos
problèmes de macintosh ouais je vous
racontais tout un oui je raconte tout en
effet cette émission a bien sûr venir il
parle de l'édition qui l'a regardé où tu
étais on va voir alors vous parlez de la
déchéance de votre mère vieillissante
problèmes de fric avec les impôts car la
banque un ça va
pas facile et vous parle effectivement
page 425 de tout le monde en parle
émission à laquelle assistaient elie
semoun présent ce soir
alors je te refais le truc alors moi je
te dis
elie semoun vous avez déclaré que les
juifs étaient sous représentés à la
télévision et toi tu me réponds c'était
de l'humour évidemment c'est exactement
ce que j'allais dire ouais moi je te dis
vous savez si un goy disait ça il serait
viré le lendemain et toi tu réponds oui
c'est peut-être de l'humour à l'envers
voilà donc ça cet échange a été noté par
renaud camus dans son journal donc qui
sort aujourd'hui retour à canossa
alors ce qui est extraordinaire moi
quand j'ai lu votre journal et je suis
tombé là dessus mais ça a un sens c'est
parce que c'est ça en fait qu'on vous a
reproché la fameuse affaire renaud camus
c'est ce que lui fait avec humour et que
vous avez fait peut-être avec moins
d'humour vous n'êtes pas elie semoun a
peut-être vous êtes client tous les cas
et alors quand on lit votre bouquin page
417 apparaissent les prémices de ce
qu'on a appelé après laffaire renaud
camus que je vais essayer de résumer
dites moi si je me trompe
l' affaire commence donc en l'an 2000
avec la parution chez fayard d'un de vos
bouquins qui s'appelle la campagne de
france quel journal 1994
bon tout va bien vous sortez votre
journal c'est lui le premier ni le
dernier voilà et puis un jour il ya un
critique peut-être un peu plus courageux
que les autres aux inrockuptibles qui
lie le bouquin entier
oui et et qui publie un papier dans les
inrockuptibles intitulé la peste noire
où il révèle un passage de votre livre
consacré à l'émission de france culture
qui s'appelle panorama et vous dit
exactement il m'agace et m'attriste de
voir et d'entendre cette culture et
cette civilisation avoir pour principaux
porte-parole
une majorité de juifs français de
première ou de la seconde génération
c'est à dire que ce que et lydie sur le
plateau de cette émission était pas de
parler de moi en fait
ce qu' il y dix hauts plateaux de cette
émission disons en faisant du deuxième
degré vous vous le dites au premier
degré dans votre journal vous remarquez
la sur représentation de collaborateurs
juifs dans l'émission de france culture
panorama visitent paca n'a trop vous dit
que il ya que ça je dis que ils sont en
effet assez nombreux et que cette
émission est qu'ils ont tendance à
parler plutôt de questions d'intérêt
juif c'est à dire souvent je serai très
grand intérêt
on reproche est en somme qu'une émission
à vocation généraliste est en train de
prendre à côté qui me semble à tort ou à
raison ça peut se discuter communautaire
je n'ai rien contre les émissions kobe
l'auteur en gros excusez moi je reste
posée mais les spectateurs vous dites
c'est france culture c'est par radio j
je comprends que c'est une émission
généralistes une sculpture il ya des
missions communautaire par exemple qui
s'appelle l' écoute israël dont je suis
un des plus fidèles auditeurs
des années je lui reproche pas d'être
accueillis de terre mais il faut ce sont
deux genres différents
mais on est toujours sur le fil du
rasoir quand on dit des choses comme au
football furieuse parce que ça peut être
très très mal interprété vous salue tous
et je peux comprendre que si je disais
enfin non je vais pas le dire mais enfin
bon bref oui c'est délicat parce que ça
me fait penser à ya pas longtemps là je
faisais une émission l'hyper show avec
jacques vergès et ce gars d'idées
des pseudo vérité sur les gens il dit
maintenant je vois pas pourquoi je
pourrais pas défendre ce mec il a le
droit d'être défendu etc
c'est vrai ce qui embellit parlant de
barbie oui c'est vrai qu'il a droit
d'être défendu sauf que c'est un [ __ ]
et que celui qui défend un [ __ ] masse
est pas loin d'être un [ __ ] c'est pour
ça que je dis qu'on est sur le fil du
rasoir il ya des choses comme ça nos
l'ennui c'est que je nous vivons dans
une société où à la question est ce que
ceci est vrai ou n'est pas vrai que
c'est une question extrêmement
intéressante a tendance à se substituer
la question est ce qu'on peut le dire où
est ce qu'on ne peut pas le ti diact
mais quand vous allez dis ça parce que
c'était pour l'expérience et c'était une
chose que je ressentais ajouté on écrit
des crs 2 ce n'est pas que ça n'est pas
bien quand on écrit quelque chose ça
prend plus de poids forcément oui oui
bien sûr donc il faut être responsable
de ce qu'on écrit pas ce n'était pas
très important dans mon esprit non plus
puisque j'ai dit à l'éditeur que si ça
ne dérogeait pouvait le supprimer suite
à ces jeux là encore une fois je suis
pas dans la polémique je suis dans la
vérité comme comme vous le disiez si
bien c'est pas votre éditeur habituel
pel qui publie le bouquin parce que vous
lui dit tu coûtes si tu veux couper tu
coupes lui dit non non je ne publie pas
alors si votre éditeur de longue date
c'est fayard qui publie ce bouquin donc
un claude durand et puis après quand l'
histoire commence à faire un peu de
bruit effectivement quand on leur fixeur
dans les inrockuptibles et puis après
c'est repris par la presse
fayard décide de retirer le livre des
librairies et le remet en vente
je dirai après avoir retiré les passages
incriminés c'est à dire après l'avoir
caviardé tout simplement alors levée de
boucliers effectivement laure adler par
exemple qui qui dirige france culture
menace de vous attaquer au tribunal
catherine tasca en boîte pâle parle
d'interdiction et là vous êtes mis tout
le monde à dos dire que d'un seul coup
c'est bon mais c'est plus compliqué que
ça
les parties sort et des défenseurs wes
idée joachim löw qui m'ont soutenu par
autret maintenant ici dans tout l'est
des notes ça il ya un livre sur la
question qui s'appelle du sens qui tout
à fait leur affaire et que c'est un
livre qui s'appelle du centre doit
absolument abracadabrante c'est que vous
faites un livre qui s'appelle du sens
qui reprend les pages incriminées
mais qui est publié quand même par
l'éditeur paie ol qui voulait pas
publier le le le journal de france bon
enfin et alors dans dix ans vous
rajouter au passage d'ailleurs je lui
signale s'il n'a pas lu vous rajoutez
gérard miller dans la liste des juifs
vous l'aviez peut-être oublié la
première fois je dis que je n'ai pas une
passion pour gérard billère j'ai cru
remarquer qu'il était très possible de
n'avoir pas de patio pour géré à billère
dehors de toute considération d'origine
suis pas le seul voilà donc vous
finissez par dire dans dans ce bouquin à
aucun moment je n'ai contester le droit
absolu des journalistes et des
intellectuels juifs à occuper une place
dans une émission officiel il met
simplement arrivé de m'interroger sur
l'opportunité de les voir occuper toutes
les places voilà qu on sait ça dans
cette émission là je peux dire que les
places dans toutes les places dans ces
animations la roger parce que oui c'est
tout
alors à quoi ça sert de dire si c'est
vrai et si un auteur se donne pour idéal
d'aller jusqu'au bout de la vérité est
qu'il acheva soit 7 pas choqué qu'ils
aient beaucoup d'homosexuels dans le
show business
l'étape se doit et contestable que s'il
y avait eu des missions données comme
généraliste et hutus bourde était
homosexuel et ne parler que du corps de
à oui absolument
ne parler que du
deux questions exclusivement
homosexuelles je dirais peut-être ceux
qui se moquent ils exagèrent un peu
alors sérieusement vidal a même jamais
alors ma parole d'honneur au dernier
degré savent absolument bien jean côté
assurent bien alors bernard henri lévy
dans le point lui il dit que vous êtes
antisémites façon maurras c'est-à-dire
maurras charles maurras qui pensaient
que les métèques n'entendez rien aux
subtilités de la culture française est
ce que ariane et qu'ils soient plus
contraire à mon opinion je pense que des
vues le comté rôle essentiel dans la
culture française qui le peuvent la
représentait parfaitement
rien n'est plus éloigné de mon idée que
la phrase idiote de morat selon laquelle
un juge de sa pas capable de comprendre
un vers de racine résultante d'une
stupidité total va sur les plus grands
exégètes d'eux a été atteint d'un coup
bien alors ceci étant bernard henri lévy
refuse la censure il refuse qu'on
interdit ce type de livre il dit renaud
camus est hélas dit hélas un écrivain et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui être écrivain
en france ça vous couvre puisque même le
président de la république françois
mitterrand voulu être écrivain giscard
voulais être écrivain poivre d'arvor va
être écrivain c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
en france même quand on atteint les plus
hauts sommets de l'état
on n'est rien tant qu'on n'est pas
écrivain déjà vous avez eu le brevet
d'écrivain c'est pas si j'avais besoin
d'un brevet de cryptage et à chercher
bernard henri lévy n'avons plus le
cantique le plus en fait lorsque je dis
simplement c'est que là vous tombez du
côté de céline c'est à dire on dit et
écrit des trucs un peu insupportable
mais c'est un écrivain l'assimilation et
céline peut-être très flatteuse passat à
côté benjoin de l'asub olympique face
aux jeunes et aux quels rapports des
niveaux ou n'avoir aucune façon les
mêmes
bittle de gizo quand on écrit des choses
comme ça il faut après assumer les
conséquences ou alors on les écrit pas
dire la celle là celle qui est reportée
dans ce volume de journal est ce qu'il y
avait beaucoup intéressé parce qu'elle
coïncide exactement avec ce que vous
appelez le début de la faire justement
et ça me semblait extrêmement pertinent
cet échange entre vous qui prouve il y à
une question du locuteur sur les bateaux
ce qu'on le dit mais qui dit quoi qui
est l'instrument de la parole et vous
dit très justement aussi la golf disait
ce que voulait dire qu'est-ce qu'ils
prendraient c'est exactement voilà si
vous voulez la faire camus entre de ce
coup là renaud camus
peut-on tout écrire même les pensées les
plus ignobles
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse tout écrire
absolument pas moi je suis très
indiscret or ce qui me concerne moi
parce que je veux j'essaye d'aller
jusqu'au bout de la vérité mais je
n'écris je ne suis pas très indiscret
pour les autres et il se trouve que je
crois alors que j'essaie justement
d'aller jusqu'au bout de la vérité que
je n'ai pas de penser ignoble je vois
très peu de haine en moi il n'y a pas de
pulsions à la violence je ne trouve
aucune pulsions sadiques
donc la question ne concerne pas très
directe me sens vraiment que je n'ai pas
de penser ignoble aurait elle alors
qu'on peut dire quand vous avez un petit
peu depuis aggravée le cas puisque vous
avez fondé bah oui le parti d'innocence
oui le nom du parti je vous concède que
c'est pas bien méchant bresse et gamme
un parti qui dit que l'immigration
depuis trente ans n'a pas apporté un
accroissement de la civilité et de
l'harmonie dans les échanges à chaque os
idées oui et la vie quotidienne vous dit
finalement que les populations qui
arrivent en france ont des usages et des
valeurs qui diffèrent j'étais content le
métissage je suis en effet assez réservé
sur la question de la métissage
universel général je trouverais oui
juste pas favorables parce qu'il me
semble que c'est la fin de l'altérité
moi je suis très favorable personne et
moi xénophobe que vois-je aime les
étrangers j'aime l'étranger j'aime les
ai mangés ranger les chez eux
rien ne dit non aussi dans mon pays dans
ma classe j'ai toujours une grande
curiosité pour les cultures étrangères
mais
je suis terrorisée par un monde unifié
où il n'y aurait plus de frontières
frontières délicieuse rien n'est plus
agréable que de l'autre côté d'une
frontière et je serai terrorisé par un
nom un moule vous serez partout chez soi
alors c'est vraiment pas parce que moi
je savais pas ça c'est vraiment pas par
hasard vous avez 10 heures excusez moi
mais vous êtes contre l'immigration vous
êtes pour le droit d'asile mais contre
l'immigration est absolument pour le
droit d'asile tous le droit d'asile rien
que le droit d'asile
vous êtes contre l'immigration vous êtes
pour le droit d'asile et c'est tout vous
trouvez qu'il ya trop d'arabes en france
je pense que tout ce que les personnes
qui sont en france pleinement loin d'y
être je ne suis pas sione l'opportunité
pour la paix pour la tranquillité pour
le dit d'en faire de dire davantage je
ne crois pas qu'il faille le solliciter
depuis on a dit cette chose
extraordinaire et c'est le dernier on a
obtenu des gens qui demandent le droit
d'asile pour des côtes
à propos de sangatte on est revenu
triomphalement il dit y en a
quelques-uns qui ont accepté de demander
le droit d'asile
je suis pour le droit d'asile certes
mais enfin pas pour contraindre les gens
à demander le brésil s'il ne peut pas le
demander
on n'a pas sollicité de l'immigration je
suis pas très favorable à l'expansion
démographique on nous dit toujours parce
que on est mais lassé de n'être pas
assez nombreux mois je ne crois pas que
je préférais quand on est entre nous ça
nous fait toujours peur c'est parce que
vous avez l'air intelligent vous et
c'est ce genre de pensée très
alambiquées pour arriver à quelque chose
de très simple et de traits que sa
pensée soit six alambics et que ça le
cas la façon dont vous parlez donc vous
l'exprimez vous si vous utilisez un
langage plutôt châtié pour dire des
choses qui sont pas terribles quoi tu
veux dire dans les moins bien mais ils
disent la même chose
moi j'ai l'impression ça me fait encore
plus peur quand je l'entends comme ça
excusez moi parce que je peux supporter
quelques divergences entre nous on ne
peut plus y avoir de débat on ne peut
plus dire quelque chose qui ne concerne
qu il ne coïncide pas avec la pensée
dominante
sans être aussitôt exclu de les changes
est traité de tous les noms
ce qui vous est ce qui vous énerve c'est
que en fait vous dit des vérités et puis
il ya une sorte de pensée universelle
qui fait qu'on n'a pas le droit de dire
que les arabes
il faut les sortir de france qui en a
trop et c'est ça qui vous ennuie je n'ai
jamais rien dit pareil pour être assez
largement
je n'ai pas le bois l'hostilité moi je
vous dit renaud camus me fait penser à
ces hollandais qui s'appelait pim
fortune qui a été assassiné à l'aube
d'une carrière politique assez
importante qui était un homme politique
hollande est homosexuel assez moderne
dans son comportement mais qui quand
même voulait renvoyer tous les immigrés
hors de hollande
comment est-ce qu'on peut être aussi
tolérant quant à sa vie privée
enfin je vais pas raconter ce que vous
racontez dans votre bouquin parce qu'il
est encore tôt et puis comment on peut
être aussi dur envers les autres c'est
ces gens là s'ils viennent chez nous
c'est parce qu'ils ont rien à bouffer
chez eux
moi si j'habitais au sénégal et s'il
avait rien à bouffer au sénégal je
viendrai en france
je pense qu'on a témoigné un égoïsme en
effet extraordinaire moi je suis très
favorable à l'aide aux pays en voie de
développement aux pays développés je
trouve qu'on leur donne beaucoup trop
peu je serai très favorable à une
augmentation considérable de l'aide aux
pays en voie développement vous avez
beaucoup d'adhérents dans votre partie
vous ne sont pas précisément un parti de
masse joindront connaissant ce parti a
un mois pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de l'inaptitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu